[Music]
this much I know we
is true I was trying to look very
dignified and then he just beat me up
some more you have to relearn how to
walk and talk it was crazy you have to
watch this season yeah grab those
tissues because you're gonna need them
for season 21 of American Idol
specifically for 24 year old contestant
Elijah McCormick I was in the hospital
for 79 days had about 10 surgeries
dialysis
[Music]
thankful to be here honestly I think you
naturally get really
um emotionally tired of these kids and
their struggles and their Journeys
Elijah's Journey it had some dark roads
he was in a car accident just hours
after his 2019 High School graduation I
flatlined a couple times in the process
of being airlifted and then I flatlined
a couple times on the operating table
total of nine times
I would have never expected to go
through something like that I'm about to
go out there give it everything I have
Elijah chooses the fitting track for the
audition Bless the Broken Road by Rascal
Flatts
[Music]
left along the broken road
but I got lost a time or two
wipe my brow and Care pushing through
what's your favorite part of being on
the road together this season gang
finding an incredible Talent couldn't
see how every sign for you straight to
you
at one point Katy Perry Comforts Lionel
Richie at the judges table Lionel
clearly overwhelmed by the powerful
performance business
[Music]
I've always been connected to my
emotions Lionel it led me to where you
are
and now I'm just rolling
home into my lovers arms Elijah's
audition ends on a high note the judges
specifically request his mom join them
and that's when the Goosebumps get
really real well God bless you and your
family and that Golden Child right there
it's crazy you said Golden Child my ID
got burnt up in the car and that's what
they called me on that whole floor in
the hospital was Golden Child that's
crazy
no doubt Elijah faced serious challenges
along the way but now you could say
everything's coming up gold hey we got
to do it right one two three you're
going to Hollywood
the bottom line is to
um
just give them the platform to follow
their dreams and support them that God
bless
the Broken Road
to you